language it's how we express ourselves
inspire connect language has helped our
society evolve where there is human
experience there is language what if we
can find insights in all that speech and
all that text that's around us modern
computing is now reaching the power to
process human language from capabilities
like universal translation to
summarizing legal documents and even
understanding human emotion we're just
beginning to explore the possibilities
that's why we've developed the natural
language processing nanodegree program
master the skills that are changing the
world you'll build a github portfolio of
projects with machine translation neural
networks and speech recognition because
when you teach computers to not just
understand language but to actually
generate new communication you can help
take the human experience to a whole new
level
Georgina said Udacity get started and
then help
[Music]